dans un vieux carton j'ai retrouvé la
raquette de ping pong et comme j'étais
petit le vin mais aussi la carte de
clubs assez drôle je suis pas pourquoi
tu es que je montre cette photo à des
gens ils ont toujours la même réaction
moi c'est bizarre parce que enfin quand
j'étais petit il est bon plus tard la
taïga du coup ça m'a donné envie de
réessayer dans un club de ping pong
alors j'ai essayé le plus important
c'est quand même le croit parce qu'il ya
un prof de ping pong qui t'expliquent
qu'il faut taper dans la balle et ce
monsieur correctement très heureusement
on dira qu'il veut te montrer qui c'est
un groupe i cévennes en fait évidemment
la raquette on la tient de manière à
bondues muscles tu apprends aussi que
les ceintures une raquette
il ya un côté noir et un petit rouge
parce que je veux dire c'est que t'as
pas le droit d'avoir un côté noir et un
côté noir
alors je demande pour pas et ceci
explique que l'on peut faire des
stratégies
là je me suis rendu compte que les
genres de ping pong c'est toujours un
peu les mêmes pour bien sûr y'a chinois
bien un mec qui joue avec le poignet
complètement casse est là et là une
position relativement efféminé et la
bouche un plat ouverte ce qui fait quand
tu le vois la sensation le trouvé
dégueulasse avec la bouche ouverte à un
autiste cet homme notice en fait
présente sur une fille
[Musique]
c'est me fit meliti elle joue de manière
très stoïque contre la table avec la
juste à main qui bouffe et le corps
totalement fixe viennent toujours ce
match parce que elle est tellement
bizarre
alors évidemment j'ai perdu contre une
fille j'ai pas peur
j'ai pas peur de perdre mes skis mots ce
qui motive ce qui me fait battre le
coeur ce qui me donne mon énergie c'est
avant tout la ça avant tout le savons
tous mes gosses donc à monsieur k
fine direct à une grave maladie qui joue
que pour s'en sortir pour essayer
d'oublier
c'est bizarre parce qu'il parle assez
fort mais en ce qui te regardent comme
s'ils devaient répondre un truc rouge et
le bleu est aussi le mec qui suit les
cours de manière très assidu de paraza
dès qu'ils refusent pour qu'on fasse une
balle genre pas dans le match
on peut juste mais on m'a dit qu'on
devait jouer peut jouer ce genre de mec
en général et éclate et après et
explique pourquoi tu as perdu 21,01
c'est pas grave c'est pas grave
ces deux revers puis après il ya moi
excuse moi on peut avons pu utiliser ma
balle pour le match pour jouer parce que
c'est un peu par bonheur et tout bon
maintenant on peut pas non j'ai dit
bonjour aux murs oui en le ping pong
c'est par un sport venir ben moi c'était
ce que je disais avant et puis après je
suis donc rentrée chez moi aidez moi à
l'ale sos suite à cette expérience j'ai
décidé de l'arrêter ce sport enfin parce
que je ne sentais pas à ma place puis
bon je te mettre à la marche
bon ça fait quelques années que ça me
trotte
j'aime bien marché j'ai bien marché dans
les villes et dans les campagnes
donc petite annonce personnel s'il ya
des gens qui voient là qui font de la
marche qui sont carrément gérant d'un
club de marche
contactez moi